i think this last thing with with these
liberals is the atheist thing i think
the belief thing they fundamentally
still believe that conservatives are
backwards religious believers
and i think that this is a huge problem
so while of course
you can
be a non-believer and be moral and
decent my good friend michael shermer my
good friend pete bogosian of course
there are atheists like that
it cannot work as an organizing
principle societies cannot work around
without something that is bigger than
themselves and i think this is now
becoming a huge problem we now live in
what i would say is sort of a godless
society that has only ushered in more
religion
and that ushers in more bureaucrats and
crazy people who just want to control
people
so now i want to link this to a video
from jordan peterson so jordan
peterson's been talking about this for a
long time here's jordan peterson in 2018
this is four years ago
talking about the necessity of religion
in order to fight tyranny and you tell
me does it sound now it's 2022 so four
years later do you think jordan's right
or wrong about this you tell me i do
believe that the biblical texts are
foundational
i believe it in the nietzschean sense
and you know nietzsche of course
announced famously in the 1800s 1800s
that god was dead and the typical
rationalist atheist regards that as a
triumphant triumphalist proclamation but
that wasn't that for nietzsche and
nietzsche knew perfectly well and said
immediately afterward that the
consequences of that was going to be
bloody catastrophe because everything
was going to fall and he predicted the
rise of communism for example and the
deaths of tens of millions of people in
the aftermath of the death of god
because nietzsche knew perfectly well
that when you pull the cornerstone out
from underneath a building that even
though it may stay
aloft in mid-air like a cartoon
character that's wandered off a cliff
for some period of time that it will
inevitably crumble and that it will be
replaced by something that's perhaps far
worse now nietzsche hoped it would be it
would be replaced by man's ability to
recreate meaning spontaneously out of
his psyche for example which i think is
a doomed enterprise but he knew that in
the interval it would be replaced by
both nihilism and by communist
totalitarianism which is a hell of a
prediction because it it was done like
40 years before the events actually
unfolded there have been terrible bad
things done in the name of god and have
been terrible bad things done in the
name of communism and and and atheism i
don't think we can i don't want to you
don't weigh them
up you'll weigh them up and you'll say
no problem we're living on the corpse of
our ancestors like we always have that's
a very old idea i think that the reason
that the western societies essentially
work quite well is because they act out
a judeo-christian ethic and one that's
essentially predicated it's predicated
on
utmost regard for the sovereignty of the
individual so the individual is
sovereign in relationship to the state
which is a remarkable idea and one
that's fundamentally religious and it's
in its in its essence
he's so good he's just so good look he's
a friend of mine obviously and i and i
toured with the guy and i love him and
he influenced me in incredible ways but
like you could hear that stuff over and
over again i mean trust me i've now
watched that clip like 10 times
and
and it still has meaning each time and
in some ways it has more meaning each
time right so he says a couple things
there that i think you see what i'm
trying to do here that if you remove god
from the equation some level of belief
some foundational belief what he talks
about as the judeo-christian ethos in
essence the it will be replaced by
something horrible and that is exactly
what nietzsche was warning right so the
atheists sort of think oh it'll be
replaced by the human psyche that we'll
all sort of believe that or maybe not
believe isn't the word that we'll all
sort of come to this realization about
what humanity is and will be very very
evolved and everything will be pleasant
and good and equal and all of that stuff
but you're seeing the fruits
of what
that has brought to us you're seeing the
fruits of it right now we don't know if
boys are boys or girls or girls we think
that being not racist is now being
racist we think that two plus two equals
five and all of those things so the
reason i'm connecting all of these
things is i think that this part
this part of the last liberal and i mean
this with love and concern and with the
desire to fix this genuinely
the the fear of the last liberal that
they'll be thought of as some sort of
believing religious [ __ ] it's like bill
those are the people that are now
defending your ability
to be a free-thinking atheist no one is
trying to convince bill maher to accept
christ or or be a believer i'm sure
there's some people that would like that
um but who are all of the people
defending all of the societal principles
that you're laying out it's now
conservatives
you